[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم مفيده
باسيلا وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى هذه هي الصور تريدنا
من جنوب الخرطوم بعد الاعلان عن تمديد
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بالسودان بخمسه
ايام اضافيه
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه الان كيف التي
تعرضت اليوم لهجوم الروسي المكثف
بالصواريخ والمسيرات ننتقل الى كوسوفو
وتحديدا الى العاصمه برشتينا على وقع
صدامات جديده تنديدا وتنديد من الناتو
وتحذير من موسكو
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
اتفاق بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع على تمديد اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
خمسه ايام وسط ترحيبه امريكيا سعودي وفي
مقابله مع الجزيره المبعوث الخاص لرئيس
مجلس السياده في السودان يقول ان الجيش
قادر على الحسم ولي يتفاوض مباشره مع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين
[موسيقى]
في هجوم نادر في وضح النهار روسيا تطلق
وابل من الصواريخ على كييف والقوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تقول ان صواريخ باليستيه
استخدمت في الهجوم وقصف اوكراني على كره
في مقاطعه الروسيه الحدوديه
صدامه جديده بين متظاهرين الصرب والشرطه
في شمال كوسوفو حلف شمال الاطلسي يدين
استهداف قوته ويحث بلجراد وبرشتينا على
استئناف الحوار لافراف يقول ان الصربه
يقاتلون من اجل حقوقهم ويحذر من انفجار
كبير يلوح في الافق في قلب اوروبا
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا حفاظ الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان على موقعه في قصر الرئاسه في
انقره تغلبه على منافسه كمال
وقد حظيت الانتخابات الرئاسيه في تركيا
باهتمام واسعا في العالم العربي وبالتحديد
في دول المنطقه القريبه من تركيا
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما
هي اسباب الاهتمام والتفاعل العربي مع
انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه وقد جاءت
الاجابات كما يلي نحو 60% قالوا ان السبب
هو حضور تركيا في ملفات اقليميه ودوليه
بينما قال نحو 7% ان الاهتمام يعود الى
حده المنافسه بين طرفي السباق الانتخابي
واخيرا ارجعه
33% الى التاثير المحتمل على سياسات تركيا
الخارجيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا بعد الاتفاق على
رفع سقف الدين الامريكي ترقب لتصويت في
الكونجرس يصدر الستاره على الازمه
[موسيقى]
رحبت السعوديه والولايات المتحده باتفاق
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على
تمديد اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لمده خمسه
ايام وقبل انقضاء الهدنه قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه للجيش السوداني مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع حول جسر الحلفايه كما دارت
اشتباكات جنوبيه العاصمه وغرب العاصمه
ايضا استخدمت فيها مختلف الاسلحه
رغم الخروقات اليوميه التي رافقتها منذ
اليوم الاول كتبت الحياه خمسه ايام اخرى
لهدنه السودان الهشه بعد ان نجحت الوساطات
في انتزاع موافقه طرفي الصراع سريعا صدر
بياننا امريكي سعودي مشترك يرحب باتفاق
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار وتطلع بيان راعيي
الهدنه الى ان يتيح التمديد ارسال مزيد من
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه
ومناقشه احتمال تمديد التمديد لفتره اطول
اليوم الاخير من الهدنه كان يوما ساخنا في
عده مناطق بالخرطوم ففي منطقه شرق النيل
قصف الطائرات الجيش السوداني مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع التي ردت بنيران المضادات
الارضيه
سبق ذلك اندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه في احياء
بامدرمان غربيه الخرطوم واخرى في احياء
بمدينه بحر شمال شرقي العاصمه كما قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع حول جسر الحلفايه لا تعرف كواليس
الاتفاق على تمديد الهده وما اذا تخللته
شروط من هذا الطرف او ذاك لكن اقتصار
المهله على خمسه ايام قد يؤشر الى صعوبات
ربما او ضغوط ويبقى الاهم مدى حاجه
السودانيين الى تهدئه تسمح لهم بالتزود
باحتياجاتهم الاساسيه ونقل مرضاهم وجرحاهم
الى المستشفيات
وتلك حال تشهد على تدهورها الامم المتحده
التي اعلنت ان القتال اجبر مليونا
واربعمائه الف سوداني على مغادره منازلهم
داخل البلاد نزوحا او الى خارجها في دول
الجوار لجوءا
قالت منظمه واطباء حول العالم انها رصدت
مقتل طبيب سوداني برصاصه في صدره واختطاف
ثلاثه اطباء اخرين واقتيادهم الى جهه
مجهوله واضافت المنظمه في بيان انها وثقت
تحويل ثلاثه مستشفيات لسكنات عسكريه وهي
مدينه المعلم الطبيه ومستشفى يونيفرسول
والمجمع الطبي بجامعه الخرطوم اضافه لنهب
وتخريب مستشفى عبد الفضيل الماضي للعيون
وهو المستشفى المركزي للعيوني بالخرطومه
وادعت الى الابتعاد عن المستشفيات
والمرافق الصحيه باعتبارها قضيه انسانيه
بحته وناشدت المنظمه وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه ووزاره الصحه بولايه الخرطوم
ونقابه اطباء السودان والجمعيات الطبيه
الاطلاع بدورهم تجاه هذه القضيه التي تضرر
منها اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين شخص بولايه
الخرطومه ووجوب مراعاه المبادئ الانس انيه
والمواثيق الدوليه وكان مدير اداره
الطوارئ في منظمه اطباء حول العالم
الدكتور محمد عبد الرحيم اتهم قوه الدعم
السريع باحتلال مستشفيات وتحويلها الى
ثكونات عسكريه
تنضم الينا شبكه مراسلين من واشنطن مراسل
جزيره ناصر الحسيني من الرياض مراسل جزيره
بدر ربيعان ومن جنوب الخرطوم مراسل
الجزيره الطاهر المرضي ابدا معك بدر بدر
هل وردتكم اي معلومات حول تفاصيل تمديد
الهدنه لمده خمسه ايام اضافيه
نعم فداء حقيقه لم يصدر من الجانب السعودي
مثلا بوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اي بين
تفصيل بخصوص هذه الهدنه الذي اعلن عن
الجانب الامريكي والتي تم تمديد لها خمسه
ايام اضافيه وفود المباحثات كانت قد وصلت
الى الجده اليوم كانت المباحثات مستمره
طوال الفتره الماضيه بين طرفي النزاع بهذا
الخصوص اي لم تتوقف رغم مغادره الوفدين
للسعوديه خلفتها الماضيه من خلال التمديد
يمكن القول ان الرغم الخروقات التي الان
عنها من قبل رعاه المبادره السعوديون
والامريكيون في بيان اول من امس الى
نمرضوه بما يحدث على الاقل من الحد الادنى
من العنف العسكري على الارض هناك فارق عن
ما قبل الهدنه الممرات الامنه هي الهدنه
وتوقفها يعني توفق توقف هذه الهدنه وهذا
امر معلوم لدى الطرف النزاع الشركه
القياده قياده الهدنه السعوديه وامريكا
كان قد اصدر اول من امس بيان تحفيزي الهدف
من هذا البيان كان يشير الى ان هناك تحسن
ملحوظ وفرق على ارض السودان عن ما كان قبل
الثاني من مايو هناك حد ادنى من العمل
العسكري وهناك خروقات شامله استخدام
مدفعيه وطائرات عسكريه وايضا طائرات مسيره
كانت هناك معالجه وفقا البيان عبر التواصل
من قبل وسطاء المبادره مع اطراف النزاع
وتم الالتزام من قبل الطرفين بالفعل
والجهات قام الانسانيه العامله في السودان
عملت على ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وفتح
الممرات وفقا لهذا الالتزام من قبل
الطرفين ايضا كان هناك حث على الاحتفاظ
بالتقدم الايجابي الذي تم احرازه والتمسك
بالالتزام على الاقل بما تبقى من اتفاقيه
تمديدها اليوم الهدره كانت قد نصت على
فتحه ومرات انسانيه لايصال مساعدات اضافه
الى مراقبه تحركات طرفي النزاع عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه وهذا تم الحديث عنه في
الاعلان الاول لنجده المتابعه الخاصه بهذه
الاتفاقيه التي وصلت على الالتزام من قبل
الطرفين وبنود ايضا تتعلق بضبط النزاع
بضوابط انسانيه عسكريه ابقى معنا بدر
انتقل اليك ناصر ناصر في بيان مشترك سعودي
امريكيه رحب الطرفان بتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار لمده خمسه ايام ولكن هل هنالك
معلومات او تفاصيل حول الاليه ان كانت
نفسها ام تغير فيها شيئا
لا حقيقه البيان من الرياض و واشنطن سعود
البيان السعودي الامريكي لم يصل الى حد
اعطاء كافه هذه التفاصيل وانما في البيان
الامريكي السعودي ثناء كبير على قوه
السودان وقوات دعم السريع على محاولتها
كما يقول تقول الدولتان الاستمرار في في
الرغبه في احلال السلام وتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار لكن اضافه الى الثناء هناك عتب كبير
على ما يبدو على الاقل من الجانب الامريكي
كما فهمنا على الطرفين في هذا النزاع تقول
ولايه المتحده والسعوديه وسطاء الامريكيون
والسعوديون يقولون رسميا انطلاقا من
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم ان الطرفين
وهما يحترمان بشكل عام بنود الاتفاقات
لوقف اطلاق النار اقدم ايضا في الوقت ذاته
على الكثير من الخروقات التي
ادت في بعض الاحيان الى سقوط ضحايا وفي
بعض الاحيان اخرى ادت الى التعطيل وتعليق
والغاء وصول مساعدات انسانيه هامه لاكثر
من مليونين من السودانيين وبالتالي الان
فيما السعوديه والولايات المتحده تثني على
رغبه طرفين تذكرهم ايضا بضروره بضروره
الاستمرار في احترام بنود الاتفاقيه
الرسميه على الاقل والترك على الاقل مجال
لتلك المساعدات الانسانيه بالوصول بشكل
امن الى الضحايا والمواطنين السودانيين
والخروقات التي تمت هي الطيران المستمر
لقوات البرهان على الخرطوم والقصف المتقطع
هنا وهناك وايضا اللوم ايضا اللي على
خروقات
سنتابع عذرا ناصر سنتابع كيف انعكس تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار على الارض مع الطاهر
المرجي
في كثير من المدنيين الذين
يتشبسون بوقف اطلاق النار ايا كانت هذه
الدرجه هذا التوقف ليستطيعون قضاء
احتياجاتهم الانسانيه والوصول الى
المستشفيات ومحاوله ايضا مغادره مواقع
الاشتباكات الى درجه يعني يرون فيها كثير
من الاضرار نحن نتحدث ايضا عن عدد كبير
للنازحين وتتحدث الامم المتحده ايضا عن
النصف السودان او نصف سكان السودان في
حاجه ماسه لمساعده غذائيه جراء تداعيات
هذه الحرب الكل الان ينتظر ان تكون الحضنه
جديده متماسكه وان تكون لجنه المراقبه
اكثر تشددا في منع الاطراف
المتحاربه من وقف هذا القتال خاصه في
الاحياء والمناطق القريبه من السكن وان
تتمكن الجهات التي تقوم بالمساعدات
الانسانيه بفتح المسارات واعاده على الاقل
عدد من المستشفيات التي خرجت من الخدمه
الى الخدمه لانه هنالك عدد كبير من
المواطنين في حاجه ماسه الى
العنايه الصحيه الظاهر المرضي مراسل جزيره
كنت معنا من جنوب الخرطوم شكرا لك والشكر
موصول لمراسل جزيره من جده بدر ربيعان ومن
واشنطن مراسل جزيره ناصر الحسيني
قال دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث الخاص
لرئيس مجلس السياده في السودان للجزيره ان
الحكومه السودانيه موافقه على تمديد
الهدنه وانها لا تسعى للحرب
نحن
موافقون على تمديد الهدنه
انطلاقا من مسؤوليتنا تجاه مواطنينا ونحن
لا لسنا سعاد حرب
لكن للاسف قوات التمرد كلما دخلنا في هدنه
ينتهكونها
ويستخذون من المستشفيات ايضا سكنات عسكريه
وما زالت انتهاكاتهم من سلب ونهب واغتصاب
مستمره
جاء كلامه دفع الله في مقابله مع الجزيره
جرت قبل الاعلان عن تمديد الهدنه المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده في السودان اضاف
ان المبادره الان محصوره في تحقيق وقف
اطلاق النار وتقديم مساعدات انسانيه فقط
المبادرات
محصور الان فقط في تحقيق
الهدنه واخف اطلاق النار تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه فقط اما مساله
الحل النهائي هذا ستقوم به الحكومه بعد
حسم هذا التمرد وستكون هنالك عمليه سياسيه
موسعه
يشرف عليها
تشرف عليها الحكومه ويشارك فيها جميع
السودانيين بدون استثناء
واشار المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
في السودان للجزيره الى ان الجيش السوداني
قادرا على الحسم لكنه لا يستخدم القوه
المفرطه حفاظا على ارواح المدنيين
واكد ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه قادره
قادره لكن هي توازن بين استخدام القوى
المفرطه
والخسائر التي يمكن ان تقع على مواطنينا
وقال دفع الله الحاج علي للجزيره ان
الحكومه السودانيه متمسكه برايها بشان
ايجاد بديلا عن مبعوث الامين العام للامم
المتحده الى السودان
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني سيده
محمد اذا تمديد وقف اطلاق النار لمده خمسه
ايام اضافيه هل سيختلف الوضع على الارض
بتقديرك عن الايام السبعه الماضيه
في البلد تحيه للساده المشاهدين الكرام
هذه الخطوه كانت متوقعه بلمس الغريب الجيش
السوداني اعلن عن طريق الناطق الرسمي فيه
في ان تستمر الهدنه وكذلك قوات الدعم
السريع فبالتالي هذه الخطوه كانت متوقعه
لكل المراقبين فضلا عن ذلك هنالك كانت
موجودات جباره من الاداره الامريكيه
والاداره السعوديه لتمديد الهدنه لكن كان
المتوقع ان تستمر الهدنه الجديده لفتره
السبعه ايام لكن اتصلت على فتره الخمسه
ما الذي ادى الى تقصير مده الهدنه الجديده
من سبعه ايام الى خمسه
تقدير هنالك العديد من العوامل منها
الخلاف الذي الان يدور بين الحكومه
السودانيه وكذلك البعثه
فيروسا الى خرطوم فضلا عن ذلك التقرير
الذي صدر امس عن اللجنه المشتركه بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سينما
حملت الطرفين انتهاكات من قبل بعض الافراد
والعناصر المتمثله في مصادره بعد الادويه
وكذلك هنالك بعض الهجمات التي مستمره حتى
يؤمن هذا لطرفه الصرع يبدو ان هذا الموقف
لم يعجب الله السلطات السودانيه ممثله في
الجيش السوداني باعتبار ان كل التصريحات
تتحدث بان هي تقوم بردات الفعل اي بمعنى
ان قوات الدعم السريعيه التي تحاول اقتحام
بعض المقرات كقاعده وادي سيدنا وكذلك مطار
المبيض وغيرها من المناطق والقوات المسلحه
تستخدم الطيران في اطار الدفاع وبالتالي
ربما هي الجيش السوداني غير راضي عن هذه
تصريحات بتحميله المسئوليه لذا كان لديه
تردد في ان يوافق على هذه الهدنه بنفس
الشروط باعتبار ان الهدنه السابقه في
تقدير لن تختلف كثيرا مع الهدنه التي تم
اطلاقها الان باعتبار ما زالت المستشفيات
لم تعود الى الخدمه هنالك نقصيه كامل في
الامدادات الدوائيه والطبيه وكذلك حتى
المواد الايقافيه فضلا عن ذلك ما زالت
المجموعات العسكريه لاسيه مع عناصر الدعم
السريع موجوده في الاحياء وفي السكنات
وبالتالي من الصعب جدا ان تتغير هذه
المعطيات ما لم تكن هنالك جديه ودور فاعل
اكثر للرقابه باعتبار ان فاعليه استخدام
الاقمار الصناعيه او العناصر التي تم
تسميتها كمراقبين من قبل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عناصر محدوده جدا لا يمكن ان تكون فاعله
في رصد الاحداث وكان في ولايه الخرطوم
التي تتجاوز مساحتها
ولايه بعض المناطق الاخرى فبالتالي
ان نرى كيف سينعكس هذا التمديد على الارض
شكرا لك محمد داتورشين الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
تعرضت لعاصمه الاوكرانيه كياف لهجوم مكثف
بصواريخ باليستيه اليوم وذلك عقب تعرضها
لهجمات ليليه بصواريخ مجنحه ومسيرات
انتحاريه وتزايدت وتيره استهداف العاصمه
منذ بدايه شهر مايو جاري وسط تحضيرات من
استنزاف الدفاعات الجويه
تزداد وتييرتها وكثافتها كل يوم
هكذا بدا حال العاصمه كييف بعد هجوم ليلي
جديد بالصواريخ والمسيرات
لكن حالها نهارا لم يكن مختلفا هجمه
صاروخيه وانفجارات لم تهدا بالتزامن مع
عمل الدفاعات الجويه روعت حياه سكان
العاصمه فهرعوا الى محطات المترو للاحتماء
مشاهد تعيد الى الاذهان صور بدايات الحرب
وربما اصعب اما المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه فافصح عن طبيعه الهجوم
ما يقرب من عشره صواريخ بالستيا اطلقت
خلال الهجوم الجديد على كييف انها على
الاغلب من نوع اسكندر هناك دقائق معدوده
لرصد الصواريخ الباليستيه لحظه اطلاقها
وخصوصا عند اطلاقها من منصات ارضيه
على رؤوس العابرين هنا سقط حطام احد
الصواريخ في واحد من شوارع المدينه لم
تفصح السلطات عن طبيعته بعد ولا عن حجم
الاضرار في مواقع غير هذه استهدفت دون
السماح لنا بتصويرها لحساسيتها الكبيره
ورغم التصريح باصابه شخص فقط واسقاط جميع
الاهداف
ظهر رئيس الاستخبارات متواعدا من يهدد
بلاده
لقد هزمنا اولئك الذين لا زالوا يؤمنون او
يعتقدون او ربما يحلمون بانهم يستطيعون
تهديد بلادنا اما من عايش هذه الهجمات من
السكان فباتوا يعبرون عن حيرتهم اذا
الواقع الجديد
على سماع سفارات الانذار في كييف طيله سنه
ونصف من الحرب وظننا ان كل شيء على ما
يرام لكننا الان نفاجئ بحجم وكثافه
الضربات ولم نعد نفهم ما يحدث تماما
اسئله
هذه الهجمات المكثفه نحو عاصمتهم ومدنهم
في كل الاوقات الى متى ستستمر والى اي مدن
يمكن ان تصل وحتى متى ستتمكنوا الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه من الاستمرار في
اعتراضها في ظل تحذيرات رسميه من محاولات
استنزافها تتعدد تساؤلات لكن وحتى هذه
اللحظه
تغيب الاجابات حسن مسعود الجزيره كيف
من جانبا اخر قال حاكموا بالجورود الروسيه
ان قصفا اوكرانيا استهدف مؤسستين صناعيتين
في المقاطعه واقع اربع ضحايا كما افادت
وسائل اعلام روسيه بتعرض عدد من القرى في
مقاطعه بلغورود الحدوديه لقصف اوكراني ب
30 قذيفه مدفعيه
ونشرت مقاطع مصوره تظهر اعمده الدخان في
المناطق المستهدفه
[موسيقى]
ينضم
اليناك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع السيد جوري
هنالك مخاوف من ان تؤدي هذه الهجمات
المكثفه على اكياس من استنزاف الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه
مساء الخير ان الهجمات الاخيره بالفعل
كانت هجمات مكثفه هي هجمات ارهابيه روسيه
على المدينه الاوكرانيه السلميه نحن نتحدث
عن الهجوم السادس عشر وفي خلال الساعات 24
الماضيه كان لدينا موجتان من الصواريخ
الاولى حصلت في الليل
واسقطنا 27 صاروخ مجنح بالاضافه الى 20
طائره مسيره ايرانيه اطلقها الروس واليوم
في خلال ساعات النهار اسقطنا احد عشر
صاروخا بالستيا وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
دليل اضافي بان روسيا هي دوله ارهابيه غير
قادره على تحقيق النجاحات الميدانيه تحاول
روسيا وبكل ياس ان تحقق الاهداف بهذه
الطريقه من خلال استهداف المدن الاوكرانيه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دعا الى تعزيز
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه وتزويد
اوكرانيا
16 هل تلقيتم اي وعود بتعزيز الدفاعات
الجويه هنالك وعود بتزويد اوكرانيا بهذه
الطائرات ولكن الى حد الان لم يتم ذلك
هل هنالك استجابه
البدايه لقد حصلنا على دفاعات جويه مهمه
من مثل
الانظمه التي حصلنا عليها من الحلفاء
بالاضافه الى المنظومات الاخرى وهناك
منظومات اصغر حصلنا عليها من المانيا او
حتى من المملكه المتحده من الولايات
المتحده من اسبانيا وبالتالي تم تعزيز
منظومه الدفاعات الجويه بالنسبه الينا لكي
نتمكن من الدفاع عن انفسنا في مواجهه
مجرمي الحرب الروس ولكننا بحاجه الى
طائرات اف 16 لان اوكرانيا هي بلد كبير
وليس باستطاعتنا ان ندافع عن مدننا من
خلال المنظومات الارضيه فقط نحن نتحدث عن
طائرات
طائرات الاف سته عشر التي يمكنها ان تغطي
الاجواء الاوكرانيه سوف هذه الطائرات
ونتعاون مع الحلفاء والتدريب سوف يتم في
القريب العاجل وهناك عدد من الحلفاء في
اوروبا وفي اماكن اخرى في العالم عبروا عن
جاهزيتهم بتزويدنا 16 هولندا الدنمارك
ومعدات هل لديكم رفاهيه الانتظار هل يمكن
لكم الصمود
بكليه تاكيد يمكننا ان ننتظر وسوف ننتظر
وتمكنا من مقاومه الاعتداء الروسي لاكثر
من 14 شهرا الان لقد اوقفنا الروس في
تقدمهم
وابقيناهم خارج المدن الاساسيه خرسون
نحن نعرف ان طائرات الاف سته عشر هي
الطائرات متقدمه لا يمكن ان نحصل عليها
بين ليله وضحاها هذا ما نفهمه ولكن نحن
بحاجه الى هذه الطائره الان نحصل على
صواريخ بعيده المدى من الحلفاء نستخدم هذه
الصواريخ بطريقه فعاله وسوف تشعر روسيا
بشكل متزايد بوقعي ردنا سوف نعمل بما
لدينا الان وفي الوقت نفسه سوف نتواصل مع
حلفائنا للتاكد من الحصول على طائرات اف
16 شكرا لك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
والمتحدثه باسم وزاره الد فاع كنت معنا
ينضم الينا من موسكو
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي سيد اندريه
اذا هنالك تكثيف
للهجمات الروسيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ما الهدف من ذلك خاصه ان الجانب الاوكراني
يقول بانه اسقط كل هذه الصواريخ او
المسيرات على اختلاف انواعها ليس كلها بل
اغلبها
البدايه كيف لم تكن المدينه الوحيده
المستهدفه نحن نتحدث عن مناطق اخرى في
اوكرانيا طالتها هذه الصواريخ والمسيرات
الروسيه الفكره الاساسيه تقضي
بتدمير المخزون العسكري من معدات ومن وقود
ومن ذخيره بالنسبه الى القوات الاوكرانيه
هذا هو الهدف الرئيس النقطه الثانيه هي ان
روسيا تحاول ان تدمر منظومات الدفاع الجوي
التي حصلت عليها اوكرانيا من دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي وذلك للقضاء على هذه القدرات التي
تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه في كل ارجاء
اوكرانيا نحن لا نفشي سرا اذا ما قلنا ان
اوكرانيا تحاول ان تنشر قواتها الان تجه
يزا لهجوم يستهدف الاراضي الروسيه من خلال
الويه ومن خلال مئات الدبابات والمعدات
التي حصلت عليها القوات الاوكرانيه
بتاعك وهو يقول بان الجانب الاوكراني قادر
على الصمود وفق الامكانات التي تتوفر لديه
ووعد الجانب الروسي بان يرى الردود
الاوكرانيه
اعتقد ان هذه المزاعم والتصريحات
والتهديدات الموجهه الى روسيا هي مؤشر
مثير للاهتمام على ضعف اوكرانيا وعلى
فاعليه الهجمات الروسيه التي تستهدف
المواقع الاوكرانيه ليس باستطاعه القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تواجه هذه الهجمات الروسيه
ولذلك تلجا الى التكتيكات الارهابيه التي
تستهدف المدنيين الروس شكرا لك سيد الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
قالت السفاره السعوديه في لبنان انها تلقت
بلاغا من نوع من ذوي احد المواطنين عن
فقدان الاتصال به منذ يوم امس الاحد اثناء
وجوده في العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت اضافت
السفاره في بيان لها انها تتواصل مع
السلطات الامنيه اللبنانيه على اعلى
المستويات لكشف ملابسات اختفاء المواطن في
حين ذكرت قناه الاخباريه السعوديه في
تغريده على حسابها ان المواطنه السعوديه
المختطف في لبنان يعملون لصالح الخطوط
الجويه السعوديه في بيروت وان الاختطاف
جرى مساء امس الاحد وسط المنطقه التجاريه
في العاصمه اللبنانيه مضيفه ان الخاطفين
بعثوا رساله هاتفيه صادره من الضاحيه
الجنوبيه في بيروت مقر حزب الله طالبوا
فيها بفديه بقيمه 400 الف دولار
من جانبه قال وزير الداخليه اللبناني في
حكومه تصريف الاعمال بسام مولوي انه يتابع
مع شعبه المعلومات بقوى الامن الداخلي
قضيه اختطاف مواطن سعودي في بيروت اضاف
مولوي في تغريده على حسابه انه على تواصل
بادق التفاصيل مع السفير السعودي واصفا ما
جرى بانه يمس بعلاقه بلاده مع اشقائه
العربه كما اكد ان عقاب الفاعلين سيكون
قاسيا على حد وصفه
ينضم الينا من بيروت مراسل جزيره ايهاب
العقد ايهاب تفاصيل عمليه الاختطاف هذه هو
ماذا تقول حكومه تصريف الاعمال كيف تتفاعل
مع هذا الخبر
حتى الان لا تفاصيل امنيه حول طبيعه الخطف
واين جرى لكن الثابت انه حصل منذ اكثر من
24 ساعه وزير الداخليه بسامه مولوي توعد
الخاطفين بانه سيضرب يد من حديد واعتبر ان
هذا الامر يمس العلاقات اللبنانيه
السعوديه
وتوعد كذلك بعقاب قاس لمن قاموا بهذه
العمليه
القوى الامنيه وتحديدا شعبه المعلومات منذ
تبلغها بعمليه الخطف
تحركت بسرعه وهي تتبع لقوى الامن الداخلي
وتقوم بتحريات وتبحث عن
المخطوف من قبل الخاطفين الذين رصدت او
رصدت رصد هاتف المخطوف في عدد من المناطق
في العاصمه بيروت ويجري تجري عمليات
مداهمه بحثا عنه القوى الامنيه الان يمكن
القول بانها لاز تعمل على تقصي الحقائق
وجمع المعلومات
ومطارده اي مكان محتمل لوجود المخطوف
السعودي في لبنان ايضا السلطات الامنيه
الاخرى تقوم بتحرك مماثل وتحاول رصد مكان
المخطوف وفقا لما اعلنته وزاره الداخليه
اللبنانيه لذلك فان العمليه الامنيه
مستمره من قبل السلطات اللبنانيه التي
تقول انها لن تتهاون في عمليات الخطف في
لبنان خصوصا وان عمليات مشابهه وقعت في
عدد من المناطق اللبنانيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه وادت بمعظمها الى تحرير المخطوفين
من ايدي المافيات التي كانت قامت بعمليات
الخطف صدرت عده مواقف لبنانيه من بينها
مواقف لنواب من مختلف الانتماءات اعتبرت
ان ما جرى هو مس بالسلم الاهلي وطالبت
القوى الامنيه بالعمل على اطلاق المخطوف
السعودي في لبنان ايضا صدر موقف من مفتي
الجعفري الممتاز احمد قبلان اعتبر فيه ان
ما جرى من عمليه خطف هو من صناعه من سماهم
بالمافيات التي تقوم
بعمليات مخله بالقانون وطالب الاجهزه
الامنيه بسرعه كشف ملابسات ما جرى عمليا
السلطات الامنيه مستنفره تقوم بدوريات
بمداهمات
وقضايا تتبع امن اخرى من بينها رصد
هاتف الشخصي المخطوف وهي تقوم بما عليها
كما اكدت وزاره الداخليه اللبنانيه وايضا
هناك اهتمام سياسي بهذه المساله خصوصا وان
السفاره السعوديه في بيروت كانت اعلنت عن
عمليه الخطف وانها قامت بابلاغ جهاز فرع
المعلومات وهو جهاز استخبارات وزاره
الداخليه اللبنانيه الذي عمليا يتولى
قياده كل التتبعات الامنيه والتحقيقات
الساريه في هذا
المجال شكرا لك ايهاب العقد مراسل جزيره
كنت معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
اثارت الانتخابات التركيه اهتماما كبيرا
لدى شعوب العربيه التي تابعتها حمله
ونتائج تابعت حملات هذه الانتخابات
ونتائجها وقد صارت في مدن عربيه مسيرات
احتفال بفوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بالرئاسه ورد كثيرون اسباب ذلك
الى مقارنه فرضت نفسها مع تجربه
الديمقراطيه التركيه التي ينظر اليها
كنموذج يحتذى للشعوب او يخشى منه للانظمه
اخر صندوق لتنفجر الساحات في تركيا فرحا
في الانتخابات الموصوفه هناك بانتخابات
القرن اندفع الملايين من انصار رجب طيب
اردوغان للاحتفال بعد معركه انتخابيه
حاميه شكلت اكبر تحد امام الرئيس المثير
للجدل للاعجاب للافتتان للبغض كل ذلك معا
وكل ذلك عابر للحدود
[موسيقى]
وما قول انما يجري في تركيا لا يمكن ان
يبقى في تركيا افتئات على الواقع فقد
تجاوز الموقف منها حدود علاقه اردوغان
بشعبه وقضاياها الداخليه وتشهد بذلك حمله
اعلاميه غربيه شديده بشرت بهزيمته ودعمت
معارضيه لتصدم بخسارتهم مرتين ويتهاوى من
بعض واسم حكمه بالدكتاتوريه امام طراره
لخوض انتخابات اعاده بسبب نصف نقطه مئويه
وتقف الصحافه نفسها تسال اليوم في حيره عن
سر الرئيس الذي لا يهزم لكن الاسئله
الاكبر كانت ترتسم في المحيط القريب عن سر
الشغف العربي خصوصا بمتابعه تلك
الانتخابات فلا يفهم لماذا تخرج المسيرات
في مدن عربيه ويفرح ملايين ويترقب غيرهم
او سحر الديمقراطيه ذاك الذي عبق الاجواء
في تلك الليله من ربيع العرب المنتطفئ
يمثل اردوغان تجربه تجاوزت حمولاتها
سياسيه العابره والمتغيره يهتم العرب
بانتخابات تركيا لوجود ملايين اللاجئين
فيها ارتبط مصيرهم ببقائه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
وثم تهمه يتحدث عن دغدغه المشاعر
التاريخيه والدينيه حيث يظهر اردوغان
متماهيا معهيه ثقافيه اسلاميه وسط موجات
تغريب
ان الكثيرين تمت معنا عام وهو التجربه
نفسها خاضت تركيا انتخابات تضاهي بل تتفوق
على انتخابات الغرب الديمقراطي بنسبه
المشاركه هذه انتخابات الخمسين وقليلا في
بحر التسعينات في المئه تحت اسم جمهوريات
عربيه حاول كثير من شعوبها ان يصنع لصوته
قيمه وذاك احساس بالمواطنه والتفرد معبا
بمعنى الكرامه والحريه وبلغ من اهميته ان
قوبل بثورات مضاده اجهضت الاحلام ووقدت
الاحساس ليس غريبا ان يكون محركها العربي
اكثر ما يبغض ما حدث في تركيا
تبدو تجربه تركيا باردوغان اليوم وبغيره
غدا ما المحن مما تريده ملايين في الجوار
وبرهانا في امكان قيام نموذج ناجح
للديمقراطيه في شرق اوسط يتباهى الغرب
بزعم ان واحتها دوله احتلال هذا بلد مسلم
وصاعد استطاع شعبه وفعل فلما لا نفعل لكم
يبدو السؤال بسيطا ومخيفه
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على الحضور
التركي في ملفات اقليميه ودوليه ومؤشرات
السياسه الخارجيه التركيه في الولايه
الرئاسيه الجديده للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
[موسيقى]
قالت شرطه كوسوفو ان اشتباكات دائره بين
الشرطه ومواطنين من القوميه الصربيه
حاولوا السيطره على مبنى بلديه زفتان
شماليه البلاد كما شهدت البلده مواجهات
بين الاقليه الصربيه وقوات حفظ السلام
التي يقودها حلف شمال الاطلسي في محيط
مبنى البلديه اعطالب المحتاجون بمنع دخول
رئيس بلديه الباني لمقر عمله بعدما انتخب
في انتخابات قاطعتها الاقليه الصربيه ولم
تتجاوز نسبه المشاركه فيها اربعه في المئه
وعيارات مطاطيه فيزافي تشان شماليه كوسوفو
هذا منتهى اليه التجمع لمحتجين صدق غاضبين
في محيط مبنى البلدي يرفضون نتائج
انتخابات قطعوها وافضت الى فوز رئيس بلديه
من الاقليه الالبانيه في بلدته
حاصروا عربات الشرطه الكسوفيه مطالبين
بمغادرتها ورفعوا عليها رايات صربيا دون
ان يثنيهم عن ذلك الانتشار الكبير لقوته
السلام
انت قلق على عناصرك ونحن قلقون على اهلنا
عليكم ازاله عربات شرطه كوسوفو من هنا نحن
نصدقكم ويمكنكم البقاء وسنتظاهر سلميا اذا
بقيتم وحدكم
رفضت التراجع عن اجراءاتها رغم الاذانات
الدوليه مؤكده حاجه المجتمعات المحليه الى
تقديم الخدمات البلديه اما صربيا التي لا
تعترف بكوسوفو دوله فتطالب بانشاء اتحاد
للبلديات الصربيه في المناطق التي تقطنها
اغلبيه من هذه القوميه داخل كوسوفو وتعتبر
الوضع الراهن مدعاه لوضع جيشها في حاله
تاهب لحمايتهم
هذه التوترات الجديده تاتي بعد اشهر من
مفاوضات رعاها الاتحاد الاوروبي ودعمتها
الولايات المتحده للاتفاق على مسار لتطبيع
العلاقات بين كوسوفو وصربيا مسار لا يصل
الى حد الاعتراف المتبادل لكنه يسهل
التعاملات اليوميه بين المجتمعات
المتجاوره وهو كما تثبت الاحداث الراهنه
لم ينتقل بعد الى حيز الفعل يتمسك الطرفان
بموقفيهما حتى الان رغم المناشدات الدوليه
فحكومه برشتينا تعتبر تنصيب رؤساء
البلديات الجدد واجبا دستوريا بينما تراه
بالجراد تعديا على الاقليه الصربيه وان
كانت قوته كييفورد تحاول منع انزلاق
التوتر الى صدامات دمويه فان السؤال يبقى
مطروحا حول تطبيق العلاقات بين الجانبين
محمد المدهون الجزيره من بلده الشماليه
كوسوفو
الى ذلك قالت متحدثه الرسميه باسم الناتو
انها تدين بشده الهجمات غير المبرره ضد
قوات حفظ السلام شمل لاكوسوفو والتي ادت
الى اصابه عدد من افرادها اضافت ان
الهجمات غير مقبوله على الاطلاق ويجب ان
يتوقف العنف على الفور وادعت المتحدثه
باسمنات وجميع الاطراف الى الامتناع عن
الاعمال التي تزيد من تاجيج التوترات
والانخراط في الحوار وقالت ان قوات حفظ
السلام في كوسوفو ستتخذ جميع الاجراءات
للحفاظ على بيئه امنه وستواصل العمل
بنزاهه وفقا لتفويضها بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن
بدوره قال وزير الخارجات الروسي فان تصاعد
توتر الاوضاع بين صربيا وكوسوفو ينظر
بالخطر وحذر الافراف في تصريحات صحفيه بان
انفجارا كبيرا ينضج وسط اوروبا في المكان
نفسه الذي شن في حلف شمال الاطلسي عام
1999 عدوانا على يوغوسلافيا بحسب تعبيره
مضيفا ان الوضع مقلق لكن الغرب اخذ مسارا
لفرض التبعيه الشامله على جميع الذين
يعبرون بطريقه او باخرى عن ارائهم الخاصه
واعتبر فان المشهد يتطلب حلا جيوسياسيا
يوفر امنا متساويا متكاملا لكل الدول ما
يعني ان الناتو لا يملك الحق في الهيمنه
على هذا الجزء من العالم
ينضم الينا من دبلن جون اوبرينان استاذ
السياسه الاوروبيه المختص بشؤون البلقان
بجامعه مينوس دكتور جون
الى اين تتجه الامور التوتر على اشده حصلت
مواجهات هنالك اصابات بحلف شمال الاطلسي
في قوه حلف شمال الاطلسي او قوه حفظ
السلام التابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي بتقديره
الى اين تسير الامور
اننا نتحدث ولا شك عن وضع صعبا للغايه
ولكنه ليس غير مسبوق في كوسوفو منذ ان
اعلنت كوسوفو عن استقلالها عن صربيا كان
هناك
توترات متكرره وفي بعض الاحيان التوتر كان
مصحوبا بالعنف نحن نتحدث في هذه المره عن
هجمات طالت ايضا قوات خفض السلام وهي لذلك
خطره ولكن
ونحن نتحدث عن هذا التاريخ من النزاع بين
كوسوفو وصربيا لذلك ليس بالامر غير
المعتاد
هو نفسه الا يختلف في ظل هذا الانقسام
الدولي الحاد والتوتر الشديد بين روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كيف يمكن ان ينعكس ذلك داخل
كوسوفو
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه هي في غايه الوضوح
لطالما كانت تقضي بالانحياز الى صربيا
للنقاط في مرمى الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ونحن نتحدث عن مواجهه جيوسيه بين روسيا
والغرب ولكن المشكله اكبر في هذه المرحله
ان السياسه التي اعتمدها الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لفتره طويله
هي سياسه فاشله ما قامت به هذه الاطراف
لفتره طويله قضى بمحاوله احداث تقارب بين
كوسوفو وصربيا من خلال حوار وعمليه سلام
ولكنها لم تؤتي اكلها وفي صربيا هناك نظام
قومي بقياده
هو لا يزال يحلم بصربيا الكبرى التي كان
يود ان يراها سلوفان في التسعينيات من
القرن الماضي ما ادى الى ضرر عارم في
البلقان من وجهه النظر هذه
السياسه المعتمده من قبل السيد بوتشيش لا
يمكن ان تؤدي الى اعتباره شريكا في السلام
هل ستختلف في المرحله المقبله
اعتقد انه يتعين على الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان يقروا بان
السياسه كانت خاطئه حيث ان لا يمكن ان
يكون شريكا
للسلامه وفي عمليه السلام هذه العمليات
العنفيه تكررت من قبل الصرب في كوسوفو على
مر السنوات الماضيه لمره متعدده وبالتالي
النظام السربي هو الذي يغذي هذه العمليات
وطبعا هناك ارتباط ذكر مع لافروف وبوتين
والعنف مانوت بذلك كذلك اعتقد ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده يجب ان يحذوا
السياسه جديده بطريقه جديه حيث اننا نتحدث
عن اطراف جديه لتحقيق السلام المقاربه يجب
ان تختلف النهج يجب ان يختلف العمل مع
شركاء جديين شكرا لك
استاذ السياسه الاوروبيه المختص بشؤون
البلقان بجامعه مينوت
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه اجرى
اتصالات مع نواب ديمقراطيين ولا يعرف ما
اذا كان التقدميون سيصوتون على مشروع
قانون رفع سقف الدين وكان بيضا ورئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن اعلن عن اتفاق يقضي برفع سقف
الدين وخفض الانفاق الحكومي او يحول
الاتفاق في حال تمريره من الكونجرس دون
تخلف الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
للمره الاولى في تاريخها وقد حذرت الحكومه
الامريكيه من التخلف عن السداد بحلول
الخامس من يونيون المقبل
الاتفاق بين الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس مجلس
النواب كذا مكارثي على رفع سقف الدين وخفض
الانفاق الحكومي يجنب الولايات المتحده
التخلفا للمره الاولى عن سداد ديونها
ويتضمن الاتفاق بنودا ابرزها رفع سقف
الدين لعامين وتثبيت الانفاق الحكومي غير
الدفاعي لعام 2024
وزيادته بنسبه واحد في المئه عام 2025
وتشديد شروط الحصول على الاعانات
الاجتماعيه مع استثناء الضمان الاجتماعي
والتامين الصحي للمسنين من التخفيضات
ويمثل الاتفاق تسويه الزمه البيت الابيض
والقياده الجمهوريين النيابيه تقديم
تنازلات ومع ذلك اعتبر كل طرف انه حقق
انتصارا
يحول الاتفاق دون اسوا كارثه ممكنه وهي
التخلف عن سداد الديون للمره الاولى في
تاريخ امتنا وركود اقتصادي وتدمير لمخصصات
التقاعد وخساره ملايين الوظائف كما يحمل
الاتفاق اولويات اساسيه وانجازات وقيما
حاربت انا والديمقراطيون طويلا من اجلها
بدوره اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب كذا مكارث
الاتفاق انجازا لمصلحه الجمهوريين
ومن المقرر ان يصوت مجلس النواب على
الاتفاق يوم الاربعاء المقبل قبل ان ينتقل
الى مجلس الشيوخ في ظل توقعات ببروز اصوات
معترضه عليه في صفوف الحزبين
عمل على الاتفاق خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
ودققها في تفاصيل هذا التشريع وقد اكد من
ان كتلتهما التشريعيتين لديهم الاصوات
الكافيه لتمرير التشريع في مجلسي النواب
وشيوخ وبناء عليه سيتعين على الحزبين
التواصل مع المشرعين وشرحه حقيقه ان كل
طرف حصل على شيء ما اراده
وكانت وزيره الخزانه حذرت من ان الحكومه
الامريكيه سوف تتخلف عن سداد ديونها بحلول
الخامس من يونيو حزيران ما لم يتم الاتفاق
على رفع سقف الدين
الالتف رفع سقف الدين خلف ارتياحا في
الولايات المتحده لكنه يواجه معارضه
محتمله في الكونجرس من الجناح التقدمي في
الحزب الديمقراطي والمحافظ في الحزب
الجمهوري فادي منصور الجزيره واشنطن
من خلال معادله تاثر والتاثير وبحكم
موقعها الجغرافي الاستراتيجي وثقلها
السياسي والاقتصادي والعسكري سجلت تركيا
خلال سنوات من حكم الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
حضورا لافتا في ملفات دوليه عده اذا تحاول
تركيا موازنه علاقاتها مع حلفائها
الغربيين تحت مظله الناتو من جهه ومع
روسيا التي باعتها عام 2019 عددا من انظمه
صواريخها للدفاع الجوي اس 400 لكن ماذا عن
الموقف من الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
برزت تركيا هنا وسيطا في صفقه تجاريه سمحت
بتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر البحر
الاسود الى بقيه دول العالم رفضت انقره
تماهي مع العقوبات الغربيه على موسكو
لكنها في الوقت نفسه باعت كياف طائرات
مسيره عسكريه من طراز بيرق دار وهي ذات
المسيرات التي رجحت كفه اذربيجان في
المواجهه العسكريه الاحدث مع ارمينيا على
خلفيه الصراع المستمر بينها منذ عقود حول
اقليم كرابه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا
بك دكتور خليل دكتور خليل الى اي مدى نجحت
انقره في عهده الرئيس اردوغان في الموازنه
بين علاقاتها ضمن الناتو وعلاقاتها مع
روسيا وهل سيبقى الامر على نفس النهج في
هذه العهده الجديده
بشكل عام نجحت الى حد بعيد في عامل نوع من
التوازن بين علاقاتها باعتبارها دوله في
حلف النيتو وكمان حليف مهم جدا للغرب وفي
نفس الوقت ايضا حصل علاقه جيده جدا مع
روسيا المتورطه بشكل اخر في الملفات
المنطقه العربيه خاصه في سوريا وشمال
افريقيا وبالتالي هناك حاجه للتوازن هل لم
تتغير في مستقبل لا اعتقد ذلك نحن اذا
حاجه غربيه ماسه جدا لتركيا باعتبارها
اولا عضو مهم جدا في حلف الناتو ثانيا
لديها علاقات جيده مع كل الاطراف الصراع
سواء روسيا اوكرانيا وبالتالي تقوم بدور
رمانه ميزان في هذه المنطقه بالتفاوض مع
ثلاث طرفين وهناك كما ذكرته ما يتعلق
باتفاق الحبوب لتوقع قبل عام ونصف من الان
او عام وشهرين من الان والذي منع العالم
من الدخول في ازمه الغذاء وحبوب يعني
غذائيه كبيره جدا على مدار اخر عام
وبالتالي منع ارتفاع الاسعار المتزايد
بشكل عام في العالم وبالتالي هناك حاجه
ماسه لتركيا هناك ثوابت في العلاقات مع
تركيا خاصه بما يتعلق بالتعاون
الاستراتيجي والتعاون الدفاعي والتعاون
العسكري وبالتالي من الصعب جدا توقع حدوث
تحول جذري في السياسه الخارجيه التركيه من
جهه وكذلك سياده الدول الغربيه تجاهها من
جهه اخرى طيب ان العلاقه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه شاهدت توترا احيانا
وتقاربا احيانا اخرى هل سيبقى هذا النهج
هو الحاكم في علاقه الطرفين في المرحله
المقبله
الى حد بعيد على مدار اخر اربع خمس سنين
هناك حاله نجاح في اداره الخلافات بين
الطرفين هناك اكثر الملف كان محل الخلاف
او الملف ملف متعلق بالتعاون العسكري
والدفاعي ونعلم جميع من كان هناك خلاف حول
ضم تركيا فيما يتعلق باتفاق بيعها طائرات
اف 35 لم يتم الامر نتيجه لقيام تركيا
بشراء منظومه الدفاع الروسي اس 400 ردا
على عدم استجابه امريكا لطلبها
ببيعها منصه صواريخ او دفاع صاروخي على
مدار اخر عشر عشرين سنه وبالتالي كان هناك
ملف خلاف لكن نجحوا بشكل او باخر في حل
لهذا الخلاف وتم الموافقه مؤخرا على تحديث
منظومه
وهناك كلام حول امكانيه بيع تركيا لعدد من
هذه الطائرات الملف لاخر متعلق بملف
السوري وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه ما بين
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وامريكا والتي
تعتبرها تركيا جماعه ارهابيه على الاقل
على العلاقه بتنظيم هذا المصنف ارهابيا
امريكيا وايضا تركيا الملف متعلق باداره
العلاقات مع روسيا واعتقد ان هناك حاجه
امريكيه بشكل مؤخر لوجود نافذه ما للتفاوض
او التواصل مع روسيا عن طريق تركيا
وبالتالي هتصور هناك امكانيه لان تمر
علاقات الامريكيه التركيه بشكل من
الاستقرار النسبي وعدم وجود ملفات قد تؤدي
الى قطيعه هذه العلاقات المستقبل القريب
على الاقل طيب في ظل هذا الاستقطاب الذي
تحدثت عنه والخلاف
هذا الخلاف الذي يزداد يوما بعد يوم بين
روسيا من جهه والولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي من جهه اخرى هل تتوقعون توسع
الدور التركي في المرحله المقبله
هناك اعتماد كبير جدا على تركيا فيما تعلق
كما قلت قبل قليل بالتواصل مع روسيا من
جهه وخاصه فيما يتعلق باتفاق الحبوب ايضا
هناك حاجه حاجه غربيه لتركيا فيما يتعلق
بتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه قد تكون مش موجوده
عندها خاصه فيما يتعلق بطاريات المسيره
ايضا هناك نقطه متعلقه جدا ومهمه جدا
متعلقه بالصراعه بالتنافس الصيني الامريكي
لا يمكن على اطلاق ان نتوقع ان تقوم
امريكا بالتضحيه بتركيا في ظل صراحه
الضاري مع الصين الذي يعتبر صراع مهم جدا
ومؤثر في العلاقه بين الطرفين خاصه هناك
توسع الان نفوز الصيني في المنطقه العربيه
على مدار اخر كم شهر ما يتعلق باتفاق
السعودي الايراني فيما يتعلق بالتوسع
الصيني في منطقه شمال افريقيا فيما يتعلق
بالتوسع عدم في اوروبا وبالتالي هناك حاجه
امريكيه لعمل توازن مع الصين من خلال
الحفاظ على استراتيجيه مع تركيا عدم تضحيه
بها بشكل اخر في مستقبل القريب شكرا لك
دكتور خليل العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه كنت معنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في هذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الحصاد
الى اللقاء ننتقل الان الى السي وحسن
ونشره منتصف